[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i
momsplain it all if you are finding some
grays in that head of hair you may need
to relax
more a new study in the journal eli
found that stress
significantly influences when hair grows
gray but believe it or not
relaxing can actually reverse the trend
researchers analyzed the individual
hairs of 14 volunteers in comparison
to stress diaries that they kept by
looking at
a tiny portion of each human hair
reflecting approximately an
hour of hair growth scientists were able
to find a correlation between times of
stress
and times of graying in the hair not
only that but they also found that
periods of relaxation
correlated with once gray hair growing
out
dark that would save me a lot of hair
dye money
well if you are trying to get your kid
to eat more vegetables
there's a way pack their plate with them
researchers at penn state tracked kids
between three and five years old for a
month
and when kids got twice as many
vegetables on their plate
they ended up eating more veggies
overall they say it is important to keep
all the other portion sizes the same
as normal and what those foods are is
important too
you have to make sure that the
vegetables taste pretty good compared to
the other stuff on the plate
and finally as we hit the road this
summer you may want to make sure you
have a cool driving playlist
billboard has named the greatest driving
songs of all time
at number five little red corvette by
prince
number four the best driving song of all
time is boys in the hood by easy e
the number three song is i get around by
the beach boys
number two is fast car by tracy chapman
and the best song to drive to according
to billboard magazine
is born to run by bruce springsteen
happy driving and now you've had a
momsplaining
you gotta have the boss at number one
there's more